>> WERE YOU SURPRISED BY BOEHNER
RESIGNING.
>> A BIG SURPRISE.
I WAS SURPRISED, YEAH.
.HOW LONG DID IT TAKE YOU TO GET
ALL THAT ORANGE GOO OFF OF YOUR
FACE?
>> FOUR YEARS.
y: ARE YOU GOING TO MISS
BOEHNER.
>> IT'S A FUNNY THING.
WE COMPLETELY DISAGREE ON SO
MANY ISSUES.
BUT YOU HAVE THE RESPECT.
HE WAS VERY LOYAL TO HIS
MEMBERS, TO HIS CAUCUS.
IT SEEMS LIKE THE
REPUBLICANS DIDN'T LIKE HIM.
>> WELL, THEY SAID TO HIM EITHER
YOU SHUT DOWN GOVERNMENT OR YOU
GIVE UP THE GAVEL.
AND HE RESPONSIBLABLY GAVE UP
THE
GAVEL AND KEPT GOVERNMENT
OPEN.
>> HOW IS YOUR RELATIONSHIP WITH
OBAMA, WITH THE PRESIDENT.
>> YOU WOULD HAVE TO ASK HIM.
DO YOU WINCE WHEN YOU SEE HIM IN
HIS MOM JEANS.
>> HIS MOM JEANS?
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M TALKING
ABOUT.
THEY KIND OF HIKE UP TO HERE AND
THE FLAT FRONT.
>> I DON'T CARE
LET'S TALK ABOUT IF YOU WOULD
THE UPCOMING ELECTION, A COUPLE
OF THINGS.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE DEMOCRATS.
>> I THINK WE HAVE ALL GOOD
CANDIDATES RUNNING ON THE
DEMOCRATIC SIDE ANY ONE OF THEM
WOULD BE A GOOD PRESIDENT.
BUT HILLARY CLINTON IS THE
PERSON WHO WILL BE NOMINATED.
SET IFTHE FIRST FEMALE PRESIDENT
HAPPENED ON THE REPUBLICAN SIDE
OR WOULD YOU STILL BE-- OKAY,
GIRL, I DON'T DON'T AGREE WITH
YOU, BUT YOU KNOW, WE STILL GOT
IT.
(LAUGHTER)
OKAY.
AS FAR AS THE GOP OF THE
REPUBLICANS, WHO IS THE LEAST
CRAZY OVER THERE?
>> THAT IS A HARD CONTEST.
I WOULD NAME SEVERAL BUT I
DON'T WANT TO GET THEM IN
TROUBLE IN THEIR CAUCUS.
LOOK WHAT HAPPENED WITH CHRIS
CHRISTIE.
HE TOUCHED THE BLACK PRESIDENT
AND NOW HE CAN'T BE PRESIDENT.
>> WELL, HE HAS OTHER PROBLEMS.
AT THE INAGURATION OF PRESIDENT
TRUMP WOULD YOU WOULD BE
PROJECTILE VOMITING OR IN YOUR
MOUTH.
>> IT'S NOT GOING TO HAPPEN, HE
IS NOT GO TO BE PRESIDENT AND HE
KNOWS THAT.
>> YOU THINK?
>> OF COURSE HE KNOWS
I THINK THIS IS ABOUT BOOK SALES
AND LECTURE FEES, I MEAN FOR ALL
OF THEM.
MAYBE NOT-- JEB BUSH-- NOT FOR
HIM.
DO YOU HAVE REGRETS N THE HOUSE
OR AS SPEAKER, DO YOU EVER WISH
MAN, I WISH WE COULD HAVE GOT
THAT DONE.
>> ONE REGRET, IS THAT YOU HAVE
TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF GUN
SAFETY IN OUR COUNTRY.
WHAT IS THE BIGGEST HURDLE WITH
PASSING ANYTHING.
BECAUSE IT SEEMS LIKE NOTHING
EVER HAPPENS.
IT'S VERY DISHEARTENING TO
PEOPLE THAT WANT TO SEE
SOMETHING.
WHAT DO YOU THINK IS THE BIGGEST
STUMBLING BLOCK?
>> THE NATIONAL RIFLE
ASSOCIATION AND THE GUN OWNERS
OF AMERICA.
THEY THINK PEOPLE WANT TO TAKE
AWAY THEIR GUNS.
>> NOBODY WANTS TO TAKE AWAY
THEIR GUNS.  WHAT WE DON'T WANT
IS PEOPLE WHO SHOULDN'T HAVE A
GUN TO HAVE A GUN.
ONE TIME WHEN I WAS IN A CHILD
CARE CENTER IN MY DISTRICT, WE
WERE PLAYING ON THE FLOOR, AND
THIS FOUR YEAR OLD CHILDREN.
AND A BALLOON POPPED.
AND ONE OF THE CHILDREN SAID
DROP.
>> Larry: WOW.ISN'T THAT-- .
YEARS OLD.FOUR YEARS OLD, DROP.
SO SOMETHING IS VERY WRONG.
IT'S IN THE CULTURE.SO WHAT'S
MORE IMPORTANT.
POLITICAL SURVIVAL OR THE
SURVIVAL OF CHILDREN IN NEWTON,
COLLEGE KIDS IN OREGON.
.YOU KNOW THE GAME KEEP IT A
HUNDRED, KEEPING IT 100 PERCENT
REAL.  IF YOU DO, YOU GET A
STICKER.
IF NOT A THROW TEA AT YOU
>> CAN I KEEP IT?
>> YES. OKAY.
SO HERE IS YOUR
QUESTION.
YOURE IN A HOT AIR BALLOON.
AND FALLING RIGHT NOW.
WHY, BECAUSE WE HAVE TOO MUCH
WEIGHT.
THERE ARE THREE OTHER PEOPLE IN
THAT HOT AIR BALLOON AND YOU
HAVE TO GET RID OF ONE OF THEM.
>> THIS HAPPENS EVERY DAY.
ONLY RELATABLE QUESTIONS IN KEEP
IT A HUNDRED WHO DO YOU THROW
OVER, MITCH McCONEL, JOHN
BOEHNER OR DONALD TRUMP.
>> ALL OF THE ABOVE.
I HAVE TO GIVE YOU BOTH OF
THESE.
THERE YOU GO.